[Applause]
all right
uh big fight this weekend uh friend of
the show
israel out of sonia is out there
in [ __ ] dubai what is it you might
have arab emirates where the [ __ ] is it
fight island but it's out there
it's off the coast of dubai okay so
they're in fight island he's fighting
this guy paul acosta he's going to whoop
that [ __ ] ass
um this this [ __ ] is literally going to
be light work i think people
are like they see the size of paolo
right because he's all like juiced up
and everything like that and they start
thinking like
oh is he going to be too big for izzy
this that the other a lot of people
don't realize like izzy is [ __ ]
gigantic he's
yo that night we saw him in l.a yeah i
was staggered
when he came to the show at the yeah
yeah yeah i was that because he looks
like a skinny dude on tv look skinny on
tv and then you see him in person
and he's huge and long yeah okay
super long arm super long legs reach is
crazy so this guy is going to come in
this little like bulldog looking guy
paulo costa he's going to come in i
think
izzy is going to pick him the [ __ ] apart
what he wants more than anything
is an aggressive fighter that's going to
bring the fight to him because that lets
him do all his counter punching and
striking
just i think this is light work now does
he get the knockout i don't know it
really depends about that paulo costa
guy's chin he might have a good chin
but in terms of like piecing that
[ __ ] guy up i think it's a wrap
i think this is actually an easy
exciting fight for izzy i think he
really exposes this other guy we're
gonna order it
have you talked to him yeah since he's
been out there i had him yesterday
what's it like
where in the island yeah i don't ask him
really about that [ __ ] because like
i don't want to get in like this fight
week right like he's got like i want to
get in nobody's head
i mean like my my feeling is just like
yo we got you we're riding with you
right let's
go what's up what's going on is this his
first fight out there
i think so yeah i'll be interested to
hear what it's like because it's like i
want now
now i'm really into comparing bubble
experiences yeah yes yes yes
i was talking a friend of mine who's the
nhl bubble and it's like their [ __ ] is
nowhere near as lit as the nba was
really yeah their [ __ ] is boring up
there stars might win the cup though
that's cool being from dallas the only
time i've given a [ __ ] about hockey in
my life
ever i didn't even know the bubbles
going on with hockey one and two that's
sad because the hockey dudes are also
he's the most like uh
the biggest party animals yeah oh yeah
those are by far the biggest part of
yours because nobody recognizes them
they're out there in one oak
just partying missing teeth i heard
everybody who wins the stanley cup on
the team gets the cup for a day
yeah man the [ __ ] that cup has probably
seen oh jesus
christ oh yeah man and it's the same cup
yeah the same go up so you just add a
ring
right at the bottom whatever the guy who
is the official chaperone
i talked to him yeah and he told me like
first of all i said yo if this thing's
been around for 150 years how is it only
this tall yeah he said every like six
years they
had a ring and they send the other one
to the hall of fame
so it always just keeps moving up and
then once you get popped off it goes
back to the hall of fame
interesting and the other thing he said
was like he went it's not the real one
no it is the real one keep it keep it
one hundred the one that goes
the one that go he went to russia with
what's his name
they took that overskin oh that's gonna
took that [ __ ] russia took the
cup
oh you talking about that [ __ ] i think
they took the russians i've heard this
[ __ ] but like i don't i don't
he says because he has to be in the room
with the cup
he lost it for a week or something like
that or like they took it somewhere
there's a story where he wasn't with it
and then they have this cup which is the
cup we have today
and the conspiracy is that the russians
took it the russians took it
and they gave a replica taking stanley
cups elections these [ __ ] doing
everything they really out there bro
russians yeah they said it's wild man
it's like they're scarier now than they
were in the 80s
yeah you know real talk ladies they were
all talk
yeah yeah i was doing all this [ __ ] yeah
they just kept getting bodied like
you knew if a russian was a villain they
were getting got yeah nah man
now you don't even know the villain yeah
they're just in the shadows
and we slept on their [ __ ] in the
80s did we
yeah cause you would have like some
decent looking like russian chicks but
they all has like
short haircuts and [ __ ] like what was
that girl's name
thinking about [ __ ] braids or
whatever nielsen yeah
she was dating that guy wasn't the clock
flavor flavored guy yeah yeah flavor
flavor
yeah [ __ ] she's what she's swedish same
[ __ ] be gone [ __ ]
be gone yeah but they were they are fine
as [ __ ] dude that's funny when i call a
white girl a [ __ ] huh taylor come on
in oh that's [ __ ] up you're consistent
why [ __ ] need some respect too you
can't be out here
all these [ __ ] taylor come on come on
come on sorry white [ __ ] yeah i mean
didn't mean that
i mean didn't mean to co-sign that
disney amin walt disney
from here the espn company did not mean
to co-sign me
calling you some bhs do you know what i
mean we run out of time on a card how
much time do we have left on the card
this is the
this is the paintball one right just two
no it's not the paywall it's not pay
wall break
that's not the last time you run torture
chambers i mean
you wouldn't want that on my guy yeah
maybe we'll do that we'll do that
all i'm trying to say here is i mean we
gotta start treating people with respect
okay i mean that 100 percent
that goes for all the [ __ ] all of
them we gotta treat with respect
everybody we gotta treat with respect
everybody's
life matters all right
what do you feel about how do you feel
about the the war of uh
slogans oh man that [ __ ] is
it's the dumbest [ __ ] like when people
want to get so deep into like
well actually technically what this
means is
but i'll tell you what the crazy thing
is like i keep learning is that where
happened wait what happened
yeah i mean we're like 20 seconds okay
so we'll just stop for a second and then
we're gonna just put another card all
right guys sorry about that we had to
take a quick break man
uh switch cards could be having so much
fun with amin amino haasen go check out
my man i mean
um i want to get back to that izzy fight
real quick
or just mma in general did you guys see
the colby covington
yeah i've heard about it where's tyra
woodley do you guys see this at all
you heard about it the fight no i i saw
the
the argument he had with uh osman the
yeah yeah that [ __ ] was mad funny bro
you know do you think he lost it like he
broke character at some point
oh i think he do you know what i think
has happened with colby covington for
everybody
who's listening right now colby
covington was a fighter uh
he's a very good fighter he wasn't
getting a lot of like buzz or popularity
and then he assumed this character which
was like this make america great again
maggot guy right but he was a character
he had like somebody writing lines for
him and like scripted and it wasn't
it wasn't like a real thing and he
started to like gain all this interest
and people really invested
and like i guess i don't know if there
was a lot of maga support but there was
tons of
anti mega hate in the same way like
floyd mayweather what's up
no no in the same way that like floyd
mayweather garnered a lot of interest
off of hate like people were invested in
seeing him lose so like
colby became this villain right right
yeah and um
so all of a sudden he's this villain and
um
i think what happened to him is the same
thing that happened to andrew dice clay
oh [ __ ] oh two method lost himself in
the character
i think he's got i think he became it
and i think it's easy to become
something when you're getting so much
hate for it because you double down into
where the love is
well especially when you're making money
off of it it's like your business is
doing better than it's ever done before
business is booming for the first time
in your life you have some control you
have a fan base that actually supports
you
and you don't want to lose all those
things right it's almost like the cult
thing it's like you become part of a
cult and you're like
well [ __ ] i might not like exactly
what's going on in this cult but i like
how my friends and i have a purpose like
having a position i like doing something
like
so i think he started to actually become
this complete character that he was like
the guy was like
i don't know like early stuff he was
just like one of the dudes like super
regular
guy like not extreme really anything
like
and um even when you see him like if you
don't know who we're talking about when
you see him
he looks like a cartoon character he's
got the usa pants yeah and he's got a
mega hat and he wears like wrap around
oakley shades
like he plays the it's he's clearly
playing a part so here's the thing
i think he was playing the part and i
think now it's become and after like in
the press conference he's doing this
thing where he's like attacking like he
he whooped tyre and woodley's ass like
he just [ __ ] destroyed this dude
and they had like a beef previous and
whatever and it was
he he kicked his ass and um
and what he had this kind of like
conversation where he was talking [ __ ]
about tom really afterwards and he
started like spouting out
a lot of this uh anti-black lives matter
rhetoric that you hear
in like like from like youtube
commentators a lot it's like it's a
marxist organization
he's a communist she's a marxist right
and i understand like where they're
going with that because if you go to
like the black lives matter
website for the organization it will say
that they're
you know have these values that were
about like
breaking down the western idea of like
the nuclear family
or whatever the [ __ ] the black lives
matter the organization is
probably different than the movement
does that make sense like these are two
different entities and the movement is
focused on one specific thing which is
police brutality
and then the organization has a bunch of
different things
like who knows who cares point is he's
expatting all this stuff
and people could say that it's all
type of fights this that the other but
for me
it represented the first time that
hyping up a fight
went outside of the hacky stereotypes of
who that person was right
usually for fights to hype up right if
you're fighting against an italian guy
you come in there eating a meatball
sandwich i'm gonna eat this guy like a
[ __ ] hero
floyd mayweather's coming with sombrero
on he's like this is what i do i take
out mexicans like
it's just the lowest common denominator
stuff and it's funny to hype it up
because you're attacking identity
but at the same time it's not so
offensive that you haven't heard it from
anybody
that you're playing basketball again it
was like within the realm
of [ __ ] talk of [ __ ] talk does that make
sense like well mantra's here i'll call
luke
[ __ ] ass white boy exactly it's like
we've all kind of heard that we can act
like it's a bigger deal and
of course the nba is gonna be like super
hypocritical
uh because they're not gonna address
that at all because they pretend like
they're like super woke
but the average ball player they did it
but they did address it a little bit
they find the dude like what do you want
what did they find him you find him like
50 grand
i didn't realize that i thought he just
apologized i had not heard that mantra's
gonna find
oh i just saw him apologize but he was
like forced to apologize or he wasn't
suspended or any of that kind of [ __ ]
no he wasn't yet no right but like i
guess i guess the point is
like this is the first time you see this
you see like actual political rhetoric
in the [ __ ] talk yeah you know what i
mean yeah no it's it's yeah it go but
like even in like cricket matches
between like pakistan
pakistan and india right like no i'm
listening this is serious
like as far as you've told me there's
really funny banter back and forth
what's like what gallego
what did that mean i was at a cricket
world cup of cricket when india won the
finals
they start chanting that at the end of
match it means there's noise in the
alley
pakistanis are thieves that's what it
wow
though we're playing sri lanka at the
time
no that's some real [ __ ] no that's some
real [ __ ] because at washington wizards
games
like 10 years ago whatever when they
wanted the crowd to get loud to boost
the machine at the free-throw line they
would put a picture of jj reticub
in his duke jersey because the idea is
just like people in maryland hate
[ __ ] dude
like jj reddick is nowhere near this
match just like
so i like that [ __ ] like we're going to
talk [ __ ] we don't like you so much
we're going to talk [ __ ] about jesus
but again like the j.j reddick thing or
the pakistani industry
there's no rhetoric yeah they're thieves
what the [ __ ] is that like
who cares right it's not like they're
specifically saying
here is ours exactly they literally
if you want to think about it they
literally are leaving politics out of
sport
and what's interesting about the quality
governing thing is you didn't hear a lot
of the people who were like
stop talking about politics man
like we didn't hear a lot of that
conversation right right i hear a lot of
those people like
why are you making this political bro
that's wild that he went that far
like is that so that's the writers
though right is that the writing room
he's his theory and i i can believe it
is that he's becoming the character he
played wow
because they even push back on it
they're like wait why is he a communist
he was like
well he hates america he doesn't do
anything
he's like what is that what does that
exactly mean he had nothing you know
there where he's [ __ ] up and where
all these guys [ __ ] up i think is in
wrestling
you always get a lot of popularity by
being a heel and then you flip back to
being good yes
and he he's skipping too far well i
think what happened is he lost to kamar
ozman
if he won you think it flipped i think
what what he was gonna do is
i think it was character character
character he beats kamar usman and i
think he just becomes likable
like i think he's just like listen we
gotta unite we gotta bring everybody
together
like let's not have hate like all of a
sudden i really think there would have
been the flip and he would have been the
poster boy
so i think the ufc gets behind it right
and in a way it almost looks
it makes uh uh trump and maga look
better because now it's not this
extremist guy out there spouting
rhetoric and like
hey let's just be americans love each
other let's [ __ ] dap it up
it's all good and then he gets his
[ __ ] face broken by usman
he got his ass beat right no it was a
really competitive fight usman broke his
jaw like did someone's job but it was
super competitive
and he claims it was an early stoppage
amazing fight on both their oozman won
okay stopped him got it amazing fight
but i think after that he's like oh no
[ __ ] that i'm real with this [ __ ]
or you got to keep leaning in until you
can do the heel turn this actually
impresses me about
tyson fury he was able to be the [ __ ]
and then flip but never brought race
into it
yeah yeah he was an [ __ ] he didn't
like the guy cocky whatever
he did a lot of the [ __ ] like the flashy
black boxer would do
and he unlikeable talking [ __ ] and then
he wins and he's like yo
this guy wow they're such a great
fighter man i love this guy and he still
calls him a bum
yeah and then calls him a bum for the
next fight and then again this guy's
great you know
and i think he does have one advantage
his accent outside of accent
gypsy he's a gypsy oh that's that
that's his ethnic card that he can play
i mean amongst just white people
he's is that a thing here i know it's a
thing in europe
is that a thing here no no no we don't
even know what the [ __ ] gypsies are
right right there was that one tv show
about them but we don't really snatch
kinda
snatch kind of put us on a little bit
but we know they're marginalized so i
think it protects him a little bit
because he's like
look i'm not out here hating other
people i'm literally named after a black
guy
i come out here singing black musicians
every single day like clearly i don't
hate black people
right right right like clearly my family
doesn't hate black people and
all that second class treatment that
black people talk about
we get it baby this is what it's like i
like how black people are just talking
about it
you guys talk about this [ __ ] a lot i've
never seen it
what are you talking about it's not like
there's videos out here every [ __ ]
week
so it was a it look it's just an
interesting like
switch i think where like politics is
you you got to see this week like
politics really embedded in sport
yeah and specific agenda
you